scp-303 also known as the doorman is a
euclid-class anomaly contained by the
SCP Foundation described as a nude
sexless emaciated humanoid with reddish
brown skin and an abnormally large mouth
with oversized teeth scp-303 vocalizes a
distinct wheezing sound it materializes
behind closed doors patches or barriers
opposite a chosen sentient Observer
inducing an intense paralyzing fear in
those attempting to open the door this
fear is speculated to be of a
pre-conscious genetic nature similar to
Arachnophobia and affidiophobia scp-303
avoids direct visual contact ensuring no
individual views more than 10 percent of
its form it dematerializes before
contact is made if not obscured by a
solid object or door additionally
electronic or complex Mechanical Devices
temporarily malfunction in scp-303's
presence The Entity does not attempt to
engage with observers physically or
verbally scp-303's origin remains
unknown